this is the key to avoiding writer's
block how to achieve best seller status
in an hour first you have to get rid of
the head trash that says
i can't write a book i don't deserve to
write a book i don't know enough to
write a book
those are some really crucial ways of
getting started of getting a book moving
quickly
it's happening we got it
guys if you want to learn how to write a
bestselling book
build your brand get the attention
you're looking for this this is the man
that you need to learn from we're going
to pick his brain for a little bit
he's got a course uh i'm going to read
it because i forgot the name but the
best
earning author system on teachable
that is relatively new right when did
you put this up just a few weeks ago
it's been up for about three weeks
three weeks and how's the reaction so
far everybody loves it people are buying
it they're loving it they're learning
what they
what they didn't know about how to get
started as a writer and
uh they're saying there's nothing like
it so all good
i love it man listen i get so many
people asking me about
writing the book getting publishing
deals getting attention getting
awareness
um i in your kind of in the uh overview
of the course what i love you said
something about where is it
uh how does how to achieve best seller
status
in an hour yeah so
give us a little taste michael what do
we need to how do we get best seller
status an hour the short of it is that
amazon re-ranks
every book in its system from zero to 17
million every hour
and they have sub lists in addition to
the main list they have sub lists they
have thousands of them
so if your book it comes up in the top
hundred
in a category for even one hour of its
existence
it is a legitimate national bestseller
an amazon bestseller
not just for that hour but for all time
so the thing that you do is you go to
your list you say
hey everybody i want to help you i want
you to help me make my book a best
seller
i want you to go on amazon and buy it
between this particular hour eight and
nine pm on a tuesday night when there's
nothing going on no big game
no convention and this is a good time
for that because there's nothing going
on in the world
and then uh and then don't just say put
buy my book offer them something in
exchange if you buy my book i'll give a
free copy to a woman's shelter i'll
invite you to an exclusive webinar take
a screenshot after the hour is up
there's your proof and you're an amazon
bestseller in an hour
how's that i love it i like it i like
it's just dropping fire right from the
start this is great
how so how valuable there's lots of
hacks and there's people who will then
even like drop their
drop their ebook to 99 cents or
something
um in certain windows just for 24 hours
to start the rank
how valuable is that status to say
best seller from amazon or new york
times or any of that stuff well it's
huge it's instant credibility because
people whenever they buy anything it's
on two levels the first is the emotional
it's the child i want this
and then the parent steps in but is it
nutritious is it good for you is it
going to be okay
so when people see that it's a best
seller that's instant social proof
that you're not the only one buying it
i've got a friend who's a criminal
lawyer
and i mean he's i don't mean he's a
lawyer and a criminal i just mean he
represents
with stuff he's got a beautiful office
beautiful you walk in and you look
around the first thing you say is
well i guess i'm not the only one paying
15 000 to talk to this guy
so there's instant credibility when
other people see what you're doing and
they say
uh well you know we've made it a
bestseller so you're gonna like it too
and i guess especially if you don't have
that big an audience you may not be
you know naturally known yet this could
be the thing that you can then
put in your bio to say best-selling
author well it changes everything it's a
level of status
in a world where people don't read
nearly as many books as they used to and
here you are not just an author
but a best-selling author so it really
instantly changes the world the way the
world perceives you
and how important is category selection
when you're saying
you know you get three categories i
think on amazon right right
and for the most part amazon picks them
for you
okay there may there may be a way for
you to pick them but basically amazon
looks at the book and amazon decides
amazon is the 700 pound gorilla of the
book industry
you know we all live in amazon's world
and we just we just try to do the best
we can because they
have uh they have total control over
pretty much everything with book publish
got it so so jamin in the live chat is
asking
does it work for audible too uh
get i don't know if audible re-ranks its
books and
what i would do is i would take a look
at the the listings on audible
and see you know take a look at them at
like 701 today
tonight and then look again at 801 and
see how different they are
if you see that they're different you
know it's the same thing it's a good
question
got it so for somebody who's got that
book inside them and they're kind of
struggling to figure out
should i write it when i get it out how
do i market and promote it is that
really the goal
of the course that you've created to
help the beginner first-time author
yeah it is because the sort of you know
you can be a best-selling author as we
just saw in an hour
but you didn't really make a lot of
money from the book so the real goal is
to be a best earning author and that's
the name of course
right the best earning author i like
that thank you so
the basic idea is um you know first you
have to get rid of the head trash that
says
i can't write a book i don't deserve to
write a book i don't know enough to
write a book
look if you've been doing what you've
been doing for years then you know
plenty you know more than the person
you're trying to educate
sometimes people say well they're
already books on my subject yeah but we
don't have your
book we don't have your unique
perspective we don't have your life
experience
so you know you've got to find your
tribe only you can speak to your tribe
and then the question becomes how do you
actually write it how do you find time
to write it how do you overcome writer's
block
how do you publish distribute market and
monetize the book
once it's come out and the best earning
author course teaches
all of that and this is that this is
only a teachable right this you got to
go to the store.com to pick it up
i mean the easiest way to find it is you
just go to thebestearningauthor.com
it's sitting there uh waiting for you
and evan if you're as a courtesy to your
many followers if they want to buy the
course as a result of seeing this
if they put the word right in capital
letters w-r-i-t-e
in capital letters they'll get 50 off at
checkout so that's for your that's for
your people
all right appreciate that so again the
question here says does this genre
matter
when coming to the tactics so does it
matter if it's fiction non-fiction or
even inside if it's like
self-help or something else it really
does not
fiction's harder to promote because it's
harder to say that it's going to solve a
specific problem
most non-fiction books teach you how to
get into a relationship how to get out
of a relationship how to buy a car how
to get a job
how to buy a house any of those things
whereas fiction is a little more
ethereal it's a little more
you know just what i'm thinking about
what i want you to think about so
fiction can be harder to promote
the good news is that although it's
harder to get a deal as a first-time
author with a major publisher
never in human history has it been so
easy to reach a niche audience for
any kind of genre whether it's self-help
self-help or whether it's
fantasy or science fiction or romance or
men's fiction which is called body count
fiction because it's you know lots of
dead bodies
whatever you're writing about there's an
audience out there online that already
has an
appetite for that kind of book so it's
just about connecting with them
and with the internet has never been
easier obviously so if somebody
ultimately wants to get a publishing
deal just to say
hey i got penguin random house or
whatever you know on their resume too
does having that first one go out and
and hitting bestseller status
increase my chances of getting a yes
from the publishing company the second
time
next book yeah that's a great question
the the short answer is it definitely
helps
but what new york is new york is no
longer in the major new york publishers
are no longer interested in great books
or even good books
all they really want are books that are
easy to promote
for them and that means that the author
is already doing 50 keynotes a year
is already the baby doctor on the today
show already has a massive social media
following
if you're the person who spent your
whole time just trying to you know
develop really great content you've got
to go independent because the publishers
are going to say
we don't know how to make money doing
your book on the other hand what do you
really need them for
so you know evan someone in your
position you've got a massive following
you could go to new york tomorrow and
get a deal
the only question is why would you want
it aside from you know sort of the pat
on the head from penguin random house
because you could do that same book
yourself
and instead of getting 10 to 15 of the
cover price
you could be getting 50 if you're
selling it on amazon and if you're
speaking or selling it back to the room
or selling it
uh you know via uh via the various
channels that you've got you could be
keeping 85 to 90
of the money so the question is why
today would you want to let new york
eat your lunch and i don't have a good
answer for that all right and it's only
it's only getting better right it's only
it's only going more and more towards
decentralization
and you have to you have to control
yourself as the creator
yeah it's what you could call an arab
spring for publishers basically the
the dictatorial nature of the publishing
industry where you had to beg
borrow to find an agent and then you had
to get a book proposal done and after
that you had to go to the publishing
houses and on bended knee
and hope that somebody there would buy
your book and maybe they would only pay
you five thousand dollars or zero
dollars today
that's all over you know you don't have
to do that and most people who have
actually been through the mill with new
york publishers
did not have good experiences and it's
not all it's cracked up to be it may
seem crazy to say that
but the reality is that you're much
better off publishing independently
because you say
you save money you've got control and
you make much more money than you would
have
had you simply gone the uh traditional
room
so someone in the chat saying best
earning author given a high five
uh thank you how do what how do we so
yeah best learning offer go to
teachable.com you can pick it up there
put put right wi no wr
uh ite you get 50 bucks off um
how do you move from being a
best-selling author so we know okay
we're gonna get our
our one hour get our window hey we hit
it to now
actually earning money how do we become
a best earning author well the course
goes into a lot of the methods i'll give
you a few right now
uh there's if you call your book a
manual instead of a book
you can charge seventy dollars you can
charge a hundred 150
because you're solving a problem for the
reader so no longer is the question
uh should i buy your book or somebody
else's book for 10 bucks or 20 bucks
instead it's should i take a course for
two thousand dollars
or should you have to find a classroom
somewhere to sit in or
hire a professional or can i just buy
your manual so that's one thing
i'm taking notes here too this is great
okay here's another thing there's a
website called helperreporterout.com
you you you you know what that's about
yeah and uh
um evan i'm at the gym i'm gonna show
you this real quick
they shut off the lights on you they're
like
like you gotta go buy man don't they
know who i
am so anyway i think i just got him back
on
i don't know what the hell's going on
here so i'm going to be in the dark a
little bit but
look at you guys okay that's fine
so it's just crazy times so help a
reporter out
uh you you subscribe for free it's they
send out an ebay
email blast three times a day and uh
it's queries from reporters from the
wall street journal from the new york
times from cbs news from local outlets
outlets all over the world and if you
see something that's related to your
field
contact that reporter immediately either
he or she will put you into the article
or piece that they're writing
or they're going to save you for
background for the next time so this is
an instant way to get credibility
and then the next time somebody goes to
your website you've got that new york
times logo plastered there you've got
the quote
uh that from the wall street journal on
your email signature so
haroharo.com or howrah.org it's a great
way to uh
so those are those are a couple things
right off what's the page there's a paid
version of it too right what's the paid
version
i don't know anything about it to be
honest oh okay um
it's like harold but but paid anyway i
use that and it's not it's not expensive
like 99 bucks a month or something i
mean i guess it's
it's not immediately but yeah i mean for
for somebody who's starting off the free
version gets it done i mean that's all
that's all you need for now
you can advance later on if i use that i
got into the new york times
yeah so like it definitely works the
thing is you have to make sure you're
giving value not like
i'm an expert interview me you gotta
actually give them something to think
about
yeah so they're making the jobs easier
give them a quote give them a quote they
can just put right into the article
right away and they don't even have to
contact you and then you're in
and then once you've got those once
you've got all of those
all of those outlets have badges you put
those on your website you put them on
your email signature
and and the credibility is huge so those
are a couple of things
and then yeah yeah what what are some of
the mistakes you see
for first-time authors in actually
writing the book
putting too much pressure on themselves
trying to write too many words in a day
thinking well hemingway wrote ten
thousand words a day so if i don't do
that i'm an idiot i'm not i'm not for
real
hemingway was drunk half the time
hemingway didn't know how many words
anyway
so you know that's what i always advise
people is just do two rotten stinking
pages a day
and not just two pages but two rotten
stinking pages a day
because you cannot write better than you
can write you cannot write worse than
you can write everybody gets hung up on
is it any good well of course it's going
to be good but the thing is that before
it's good
it has to be if you do two rotten
stinking pages just two pages a day
that's going to happen half an hour
that's 10 pages a week that's 40 pages
in a month that's 120 pages or close to
a first draft in 90 days
and then once you've got a draft done
then go back and edit it
so the first thing is people put too
much pressure on themselves they expect
it to be perfect
the first time they try to write or they
think they have to write too many words
in a day
and then once it's uh and then and then
also they start editing it even before
they finished writing it
i never advised that what you want to do
is first
write the complete draft never look back
don't edit
don't edit until you've finished and
then go back and look at the whole thing
those are the those are the steps i
advise i've taught writing at ucla
new york university around the world
those are some really crucial ways of
getting started
of getting a book moving quickly would
you would you recommend
especially for non-fiction doing a table
of contents first to structure the
thinking or just
right oh absolutely yeah i mean this is
really this is the key to avoiding
writer's block
writer's block is you know your brain
has two hemispheres a left half and a
right half or a
left brain right brain your left brain
is the organizing side
that's where you're going to create your
table of contents do that first
your right brain is the creative side
that's where you do your writing from
so if you try to shunt back and forth
left brain right brain left brain right
bank
your brain hates that and it sends a
pain message
you do that often enough and you're
going to say i get that it's painful
every time i write i must be blocked
now being blocked as a writer is a great
thing because you can go to the bar you
can say hey i'm blocked and people will
take you home
because they they feel sorry for you but
the thing is you don't get your book
done
so the core the core of it is first do
the organizing then do the writing
and and it will flow absolutely do the
organizing first
i love it okay so someone here saying um
i'm a perfectionist
how important is it to be kind to
yourself well this is bigger than
writing i mean
you know i once heard somebody say i
looked up perfection in the dictionary
and it said beyond criticism
and the girl said all i ever wanted in
life was not to be criticized
and the problem is that if you're trying
to be perfect
and even if you are the people around
you are too imperfect to notice how
perfect you are
so they'll keep criticizing you so
perfectionism is not just a bad strategy
for writing it's a failed strategy
for getting other people to stop
criticizing you so it's something that
you really want to let go of remember
that nobody needs a perfect book
people need a book that's good enough in
psychology they talk about the good
enough parent
you just want to be the good enough
author if your book is good enough
it's going to soar i love it well it's
crazy how time flies when you're having
fun
it's called the best earning author
that's the program it's a it's a course
on teachable.com go check it out and
you get 50 bucks off if you put right
w-i-t-e
at a checkout where they put that in at
checkout that's exactly okay
cool michael thank you man thank you for
the time thank you for popping your
instagram live carry with us and all the
all the wisdom and knowledge you share
with us today
evan it was truly my pleasure and how
could you possibly tell this is the
first time i've ever done an instagram
live
possibly know that much it's the best
thank you man take care bye-bye if you
want to change your life in the next 30
days check the link below me
and if you want to see my one-on-one
with david bach who sold over 7 million
books check out my link right there next
to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there